okay so hi everyone it's great to be
here in my article so good afternoon
always great to be here at on campus as
well no matter
and thanks Richard for having me and
funny and Deepak here today
I'm gonna talk about what's happening in
India today in terms of the
entrepreneurial ecosystem what's
happened in the last few years and where
we see this whole thing evolving into so
Richard has given a great title
the entrepreneurs and opportunities in
India and how you know we're going to
really focus on not just the
entrepreneurs but the whole ecosystem if
we look back and what's been happening
in India there's been a gradual growth
you know across various sectors various
things in India and this has nurtured
you know what is coming out to be a very
exciting ecosystem now the question that
we asked some of us asked who went back
from the valley or from the US some
years ago all kinds of countries have
produced good startups companies which
have become great which I've had great
impacts on on lives across the globe you
know Israel can produce and I secure
Singapore couple of companies their
creative labs and so on even Estonians
produce Skype which are all become
global names with a large country like
ours a billion people lot of English
speaking people large skills available
and tons of different ideas can India
indeed produce you know startup which
can have an impact on the world so this
is what India looks like and this is
pretty much what it just looked like for
for the last few years with some changes
happening here and there you know
there's a lot of chaos but there are a
lot of opportunities we have 800 million
or maybe Deepak will know the current
numbers even more mobile users we have a
hundred million plus Internet users we
have a lot of population which which is
you know doing different
with different tools which are available
so all this really provides a good good
backdrop for for creating entrepreneurs
and creating a good platform for
creating good companies we have people
we have the environment we have a very
young population we have you know good
financial systems in place better than
many other economies however we do have
certain roadblocks we have though we
have educated people we have high
literacy there is a skills gap there's
clearly a big divide between haves and
have-nots I think more importantly we
have a cultural resistance to you know
what is called failure though it may not
be but you know what it's perceived as a
failure and other big roadblock is that
we have no early adapters we are kind of
slow at adapting to new things and there
are not too many new economy you know
poster boys or heroes so all this is
kind of slowing down what should be a
really vibrant ecosystem I'm just going
to backtrack a bit and just look at what
has happened in the past and as India
has evolved now post independence we had
a nation-building phase where there was
a lot of focus on building the
infrastructure and so on in the 90s we
had the telecom revolution where the the
telephony started in penetrating in
deeper inroads in India and that was
along with the software industry coming
up really marked a sea change in where
the direction India was taking from post
colonization days another big change of
course like the rest of the world came
with the internet and the arrival of the
mobile telephony this also led to
another industry of the IT services the
IT enable services India's answering the
phone calls for the world doing all
their back offices however what we call
the new economy which is led by products
and innovation that still not happened
we're still just doing services for the
world but all the same it's a much
change and kind of a direction towards
making innovative products and services
come 2000 vintage and we have dot-com
everywhere again there's a big change
and we have the first wave of the new
economy happening people want to make
products and solutions away from
services new business models are
emerging a whole new era of a window has
opened up and we are having a slim slice
of the Silicon Valley coming in to India
Bangalore starts being called the
Silicon Valley of India and and so on so
we had a lot of funding happening at
this time over a billion dollars
invested at that time over 100 Vesey's
started up and like the rest of the
world we had we had a market crash 2000
and you know the for various reasons
suppose 2000 again we have sort of a
lull and entrepreneurship kind of dies
down but the seed was sown we had a sort
of a taste of the market and a lot of us
started thinking we did it wrong in 2000
but let's let's do it right this time
so seed fund ourselves six of us who
were excited preneur all got together
and we said let's let's get into this
ecosystem at the same time several
others 2005 2006 several angel groups
started being formed there are some
others who started recognizing that
there we need to get into this space a
lot of the funds which were there in
2000 started being bunched up together
in the higher investment more like VC PE
types but so there was a big gap which
needed to be filled which a seed fund
along with several others started so
this 2006 I would say is the beginning
of the new age entrepreneurial ecosystem
and what we set out to do and I speak
not just for seed fund but a lot of us
who started at that time was to really
change some of the things that we had
done earlier which was to put in a less
money a lot of time so really nurture
the
startups and look at the local business
models which make sense and really prove
that PC funding in early-stage or angel
funding is indeed viable and really set
the basis for for an ecosystem and this
led to a lot of startups happening in
2006 a lot of VCs coming in as well and
really it started becoming pretty
vibrant 2008 we again had had sort of a
financial meltdown global meltdown India
wasn't so badly affected but you know we
realized that again we have to reinvent
seed fund itself which was a smaller
fund decided that you know we're looking
at different kinds of entrepreneurs so
we need to sort of evolve and again we
we came up with an incubator model along
with with a full investment segment so
we really kind of became a full-fledged
venture capital fund with an invest in
incubator as well as larger bite size
investments for seed fund itself in from
2006 since we started we've done now 25
investments all are looking at local
Indian markets with potential to go
global but they all started with having
India focused feeling the consumer
demand all the teams with experience and
knowledge of the local industries and
who all of them aim to be innovators and
leaders in the sector that they chosen
and the whole aim was to create impact
in the in the local landscape now if you
see the landscape today we have a lot
more funds even in the early stage lot
for angel groups lot more incubators
accelerators we've got some bunching
happening still in the PE segment but
again a lot of action in the early stage
so compared to even 2006 we have a lot
more action happening today this graph
actually captures it all you can see if
we started in 2000 with a dip and in
2011-12 we are we are right up there
with an increasing number of teals and
so this means that the VC
and the only stage ecosystem has truly
arrived more importantly even the angel
investments which were really hardly
there even in 2007 is gone up quite a
bit and this is really feeding into the
various venture funds and B funds a big
shift has happened also in terms of the
type of companies mm starting with a lot
of IT companies and IT enable services
that is now diversified we have several
other sectors even within technology
within IT you can see a clear change
there's a lot of online web services and
so on IT products coming up and
certainly a big big shift towards mobile
telephony we ourselves have learned a
lot in the last six years and what we've
really I think some of the mantras are
common is to promote cash flow breakeven
quickly choose the right team and look
for impactful ideas I think that that
clearly is is what we figured we can't
do copycat ideas don't really work in
particular in our ecosystem we have to
really cater to the Indian market first
before getting out while the ecosystem
has evolved we do have several gaps like
I mentioned early adaptors of products
and services access to technology and
talent these are some of the key gaps
that we do have a risk-averse culture
and we also have an education system
which really doesn't promote out of box
thinking and they work in silos so the
really industry academy our interaction
which is the basis of the Silicon Valley
and Stanford University that's
completely that was lacking and I think
there's a concerted effort now to bridge
that gap I think we will talk about that
when we go to Deepak here who is a great
example of how we're trying to overcome
this but this is something that we
really need to fix in India without that
we will not be able to really you know
replicate what we are seeing around here
around Stanford for today I think if you
look at in 2012-13 what are the hot
sectors that some of the sectors that we
favor in India
or we feel I'm going to drive the
innovation clearly it's technology but
not just technology it's technology
enabled consumer products and services
which include things like web
applications and services mobile
value-added services products and
platforms enterprise solutions India has
tons of small and medium enterprises who
can do with a lot more technology so
certainly enterprise solutions for this
segment is a big driver open-source is
going to drive a lot of this storage is
really required in India storage
solutions SAS and all these have a
potential to have to become you know to
scale globally as well cloud and
security these are again some of this
we're seeing a lot of action in around
here some of the other sectors where
technology is enabling growth of these
sectors is health care lots of services
and healthcare healthcare products
driven by technology a lot of healthcare
infrastructure this is really also
driven largely by the demand in in the
country there is a latent demand here
same thing in education there is so much
demand in education for improving the
quality for increasing the reach energy
offline consumers a lot of different
sectors which are coming up we started
by asking the question on great Indian
startups if you look at from a VC
perspective these are the ones which
have sort of made it big in terms of
having exits or IPOs and so on and we
are getting there we have some companies
now which are you know listed or which
have been acquired by larger companies
you know global companies so we've been
getting our footprint there and I think
the the roadmap is is laid out what we
need to do is to just fuel this little
more have more angel clubs and
incubators to feed into the ecosystem of
the VCS we need a lot of M&A is
happening even within in you know the
our own ecosystem we need to have closer
interaction with it with you know the
various partners and we need to really
support what we really lack is talent
and again some of the entrepreneurs can
talk about it we don't have
good sort of talent pool who really is
dying to to join startups so these are
some of the gaps so the future looks
like a bumpy ride ahead but like
everything else in India but there is
definite momentum we have a lot of good
drivers the 3G 4G technology a telecom
revolution cloud money coming into India
all this is going to drive it further so
to answer the question I think we can we
can do some good companies impact making
startups which will soon everybody will
here off and I think it's a good time to
introduce yeah I think so I think what
we'll do is we'll ask Fanny to speak
first so let's switch places back ok
Paula while we're switching locations if
I can keep from stepping on my mic cord
I've got kind of a follow-up question
for you what about the role of people
who grew up in India and then did their
education abroad like yourself do you
think they have a special role to play
in this from here is it really going to
be more local people who have grown up
in the system and are really finding
well that's that's a great question
Richard because you know having been
educated here if we we can play a great
role in India provided we understand the
the synergy that is required from the
local people we cannot isolate and we
cannot simply bring in the Western
solutions we have to realize that every
every society must have its own solution
one of the key to understanding India at
this point this new generation of
startups is really local market driven
absolutely and and I think that is what
is driven when we try to do a copycat we
didn't succeed yeah and we have to
remember that and what works here on
highway 101 will not work on our bumpy
roads right so we really need to keep
the local solutions in and the local
questions it might okay so everybody can
see the small window with finding you in
the window
as I put the slides up funny say hello
to everybody so I'm about to switch over
to your slides and you won't see too
much of yourself from this point and
I'll be happy to manipulate your slides
as we go along there is very high
personal pain points so I'm going to put
it in my slides so my slides it's a
small tech six right just gives a brief
of how we started what we do now and
what's exciting first in what we do we
end up being the country's largest
Austrian company and we always be the
largest Internet company but now we are
also the largest Austrian company a
cutting across all on the comments going
to the next right we have the strain of
aggregation distribution on High Street
sales and what we tell ourselves as to
what we do is we ourselves as online
rustically company that's the that's the
second slightly richer you on the
scooter okay so because we've caught
ourselves as a online passive income TV
for ourselves as
taking company because we believe that
the reason for our existence is the
atheistic travel agents they believe in
the more affectionate and we thought the
technologies are changing so rapidly
that online and then the whole team and
the company is up to serve customers
online and we feared that we may not be
future ready
so we said earlier we had online and we
drop the online and now we say we are a
bus trading company which which actually
changes some of the fundamental
organization structures where we invest
in a mobile phone we invest in a call
center we invest in our buying through
television sets all these different
formats we look them we look at them as
equally as we look at Internet as a
medium ok that's a small intro of whatís
going to the next slide why we exist
actually about six and a half years back
me as a customer when I went to a travel
agent to book a ticket the modus
operandi there is the travel agent makes
phone calls to the bus operators to find
out if they have any inventory so when I
went to the travel agent he made two
three phone calls to different bus
operators and told me that there are no
seats and just when I was leaving his
office to go to another travel to go to
go back he told me that maybe another
travel agent could get me a seat and
that really intrude me I thought if this
guy is a travel agent why is that he's
not able to get me a seat and how is
that another travel agent could get me a
seat but anyway I went to this other
travel agent he also made two three
phone calls and told me that there are
no seats then I went to the third travel
agent he also made two three phone calls
and couldn't get me a seat I ended up
going to the fourth fifth and sixth
travel agent all of them made a few
phone calls but
them could get me a seat and then I
ended up being in Bangalore for the long
weekend for the next day next day when I
woke up I was feeling really guilty
because maybe there was a tenth travel
agent in the city to whom if I had gone
to maybe he would have called the 30th
bus operator and maybe the 30th operator
had a seat which went weekend from
Bangalore to hyderabad that evening and
that really and that really pushed me to
go and talk to this travel agent as to
why why is that he couldn't know about
availability of that tenth bus operator
or the 15 bus that is running from
Bangalore to Hyderabad so when I learned
that I figured out that the information
about buses wasn't seriously available
to everyone and that made me think being
a being a being an engineer I thought
why can't all these bus operators be
computerized and once they are
computerized all this information about
various buses can be available on a
single place what it meant was if I went
to the first travel agent instead of he
making phone calls to different
operators he could just login onto a
computer screen and see which of the 30
bus operators had a seat which meant he
would be able to speak the binary
whether there is a seat in the entire
city or not if there's no seat I would
just go back home instead of feeling
guilty maybe there's some travel agent
who had a seat so basically that was the
idea that was the the big idea and in
retrospect actually last year we were
rated by Fast Company as one of the most
innovative ideas of the innovative
companies in the world along with
Facebook Google and etcetera we are
amongst the only two companies which
made to the world's fifty but the
underlying thing of that is a very
simple idea
when we looked at it we even wondered if
we should set up a company to solve that
so that's how we started going to the
next light well we came up with these
three solutions so the first one boss
stands for cross operator software
system this is a software which is given
to the bus operators today hundreds of
bus operators across the country use
this software to manage their operations
because of which we get real-time access
to their inventory we take that
inventory and put it on read was dot in
for consumers to use and we take the
same information through seed seller as
a channel for travel agents to use
between these three technologies a nice
network effect ascertain with more and
more bus operators getting into boss
more and more travel agents gear onto
seed seller and with again more seed
seller agents more bus operators come
onto the platform
between these we aggregate more and more
information about buses and that becomes
a compelling reason for customers to
come on to red bus ok so that's that's
pretty much the virtuous cycle which is
leading our growth going to the next
slide yeah I'm letting people see the
elements come into this I wasn't
following you as you were discussing
this so sorry about that but you can see
what's in each of the three main
products here yeah yeah success of our
product and the business if the supply
side fragmentation in India there are
hundreds and thousands of bus operators
and many of them are very very small
they own less than twenty buses each as
you can see they're about 65% of the
market is run by bus operators who have
less than 20 fleet each and that makes a
compelling reason why a third-party
software because none of them can create
their own software's and a distribution
system like a
or acid cellar by themselves so that
that fragmentation an unorganized nature
of the industry makes it a compelling
reason for the existence of bars and a
distribution system like red bus in seed
cellar even from the consumer side
imagine if there was no fragmentation if
there are only five bus operators or
only one bus operator then aggregator
like as is adds very little value to
consumer so those are some of the things
really adding to the success of what we
do then the next slide talks about the
bus industry it's about two and a half
billion dollar market interestingly it's
growing at a very rapid pace because of
various reasons one is infrastructure
the highways infrastructure in India is
very good now we have six lane and a
four lane highways almost across the
country this initiative was taken about
10-15 years back and as a result of that
today we have very good roads
besides that with all the activity
that's happening in the urban India of
more jobs more companies etc there is
increased migration from tier two towns
to Tier one town and that is again
causing need for transportation and if
you look at the three modes of
transportation that we have which is air
Road a road and rail air and rail have
infrastructure constraints and Road
thankfully is blessed with very good
infrastructure so that's causing our
growth so that's a that's about our idea
and our business and what's making it
drive going to the next slide a quick
snapshot of what our company so the
first one talks about how we have grown
in the last few years actually this is
our claim to fame this is the reason
probably I'm sitting here and talking
talking to you all we've been growing
quite well
in the last few years fanny let me
interrupt and just point out that about
6 billion rupees would be a little over
110 million dollars u.s. yeah so from
1907 zero at the beginning to a hundred
and ten million dollars in revenue yeah
okay and actually and all this with only
word-of-mouth so actually I think the
solution was the need of the are all
that we did was just created the
solution and the people just came in by
themselves and started buying tickets by
themselves
that is one fantastic thing that's
happened to us and many of the past
years went into computerizing the bus
industry the bus industry was in
computerize so making them believe in
computerization teaching them how to use
a computer to installing computers in
their offices washing away their fears
of computerization and then actually
last for five years went into that and
okay okay so going to the other thing so
we are a little over a six year old
company headquartered in Bangalore we
have 26 offices about 600 people many of
these 600 people are in the call centers
because we have a format where people
can call our call centers and we send a
cash-on-delivery to their houses we have
1,000 but soft it is 800 of them on our
own platform we manage about 20,000 bus
schedules every day across 24 states
this includes three government RTC's we
have about 40,000 point-of-sale outlets
on seed seller and 200 partners 200
partners our partners like Expedia make
my trip clear trip these are the
websites in India which sell other
travel products like airline and
etcetera
the bus part of their thing their
websites is powered by us with 200
partners they're pretty much all the
organized bustling in India is powered
by us which which means anywhere there's
a printed bus ticket where the customer
buys on bus operators own web site or a
bus operators office or travel agent or
with a seat seller travel agent or a
site like Expedia the ticket at the end
of the day gets issued through our
technology and we end up making some
money out of it we make most money when
people buy directly on our site and the
last one we are amongst the highest
transacted web sites in the country
today it would be number one in terms of
the number of transactions done on the
travel portal so that's pretty much
about the company so what's exciting to
us what makes us come to work every day
is some of the things the way we are
impacting the industry and the society
around us
the first one is we've created a level
playing field for bus operators earlier
the 10% operators were the large
operators because they have a huge fleet
could afford to have huge distribution
and by the virtue of having that
distribution they were growing they were
in a virtuous cycle and the smaller
operators were in a vicious cycle
because in a given route the large
operator and the small operator compete
for market share and the truth whereas
the large operator comes into that route
with a huge distribution whereas a small
operator comes into that route with a
very very less distribution but by now
putting the large in the small operator
on platform like like read pass and seat
Salah
both of them get a equal distribution
and both of them see unprecedented
distribution which technology enables
earlier on a phone based method
the large operator would run a large
call center and a small operator would
run a three four people call center but
then again it's it was not scalable but
now with internet technology we reach
out to hundreds of thousands of travel
agents across the country that gives
them unprecedented distribution access
so today the operators compete on
service levels rather than competing on
the size and the distribution scale that
each one has and I think and we believe
in an ideal Society people should
compete with their with their quality of
service rather than rather than the
distribution strength or other strengths
going to the next one now because the
whole system is technologically
integrated from the front end to the
back end a lot of analytics that we mind
and offer it to the industry for example
we can predict demand of number of bus
seats on each route 30 days in advance
depending on the number of searches that
happen on our site so suddenly if the
expected number of searches let's say
from point A to point B is 10,000
searches a day suddenly if 50 thousand
searches happen on the on a particular
route that is some abnormal demand on
that route or for that particular date
we immediately take that information and
show an alert on our bus system or send
a SMS to the bus operator saying there's
abnormal activity happening on this
particular route for this particular
date which enables them to plan more
buses on that route or to route some of
their buses from the low occupancy
routes to high occupancy routes this way
customer benefits the operator benefits
and we benefit because we end up selling
more seats so these are some of the
things that we could do because of
having a seamless platform from the bus
operator to the consumer and leveraging
the power of technology and information
analytics the other thing that we do is
there are also some routes where there
are no buses
for example on our site people could
just type in any source to any
destination and search for results if
people search from a - let's say G where
there are no bus services our site just
says there V sorry there are no bus
services from A to G but what we you but
we mined that information and we lock
that search and if there are
considerable number of searches
consistently from A to G we take that
information and pass it to the bus
operator saying so many more customers
are looking for this route which often
the bus operator ends up running new
buses are figuring out new routes so
that also is contributing to the
increase in the market size so various
things besides that we also do yield
management what is the best price that
is selling right now so the bus
operators tacked to that price point and
etc and all that which is causing a
reduction in wastage in the whole
industry so going to the next point I
spoke with a new a huge Network effect
that we have with more bus operators we
get more travel agents and vice versa
the the other thing that I spoke about
is the format independent organized
travel company we are we as a as a
foundation we don't call ourselves as an
Internet company we call ourselves as a
bustling company which sells which
leverages technology to sell through
internet through call center through
mobile and etc interesting thing about
five weeks back we launched our Android
app and today we are amongst the highest
downloaded hi we are training not high
astounded we are we are a training app
on mobile on Android store amongst the
free apps in India and we sing a very
very good
uprize week after week in the number of
transactions that happening through
Android phone we ourselves were very
shocked with the numbers that are
happening which was actually things are
changing quite rapidly around us just
five years back when there was no smart
phone we never thought this this channel
would contribute so much of our sales
just within five years the whole world
changed around us here going to the next
point
these are some of the things that are
very helpful to us I think this
profitability at a very low revenue per
ticket which we be owed to seed fund
like Paolo is talking about it in her
slide that seed fund actually puts in
very little money but helps the company
get to profitable very quickly so that
whole DNA got into us early on and it's
a big blessing to us today many things
in the company have changed most of us
behave in a particular way which
contributes to profitability at a very
low revenue per ticket it just got into
the company culture
okay the others are about what we like
to do in future there are many things
that we can do one interesting thing is
actually if we plot bus tickets on
Google search trends and see the growth
of people looking for bus tickets on
internet it has only been growing from
2007 prior to 2007 very few people were
searching for bus tickets on internet
which indicates and many of the searches
today also come only from India which
indicates which is also validated later
on is a service like this doesn't exist
in
any country outside India or at least
when we started it doesn't exist so it
gives us a further excitement to work
hard because this is like Google type
innovation from India actually we get
mails from many countries now in fact in
latam said over to grads from MIT are
trying to do the red bus of light I'm
there and they were talking to us to use
our technology and even while they do
they're the first ones to do it in Latin
the same thing in Malaysia same thing in
many other countries where there are bus
services but there is no technology like
this to aggregate that so that's that's
a further interesting thing for us to
work on these are some of the the next
slide is some of the awards that we got
and that gets me to the end of my
presentation thank you very much ok
thank you very much funny let me put
your picture back up so everybody can
see you and while I'm switching to
Deepak slides I've got a follow-up
question for you so it seems to me that
the travel agents kind of lose and as
you become more and more powerful is
that correct
in a very long around nothing's going to
happen in a short run ah yeah if you
take 10 15 years 20 years other than yes
it will
so have you had to deal with a lot of
resistance that they might put onto the
market through local regulators no
actually what happened was early on we
were ignored
no nobody nobody believed that customers
would buy directly on internet and
travelers and said ok let them exist it
doesn't matter and etcetera and all and
today we are kind of indispensable so
today
and also this is all grown in the last
six years so people over time got used
to it used to it that it is something
that has to exist
well they might lead us into our next
presentation because I suspect that that
might have been because of you know the
statistics show a relatively low
internet penetration rate in India and
so if you'll hold off and we'll come
back and and you'll get the whole screen
when we get to our our Q&A part but for
now I'd like to turn the microphone over
to Deepak revenge on the CEO of n oz and
talk about this whole business of
internet versus other mobile platforms
hey man how's it going what happened yep
so in continuation to the previous
discussion this is what India looked
like
we have 1.2 million people and the
hardly 10 person I have the access to
Internet and on the other hand we we
have around 900 million mobile phone
users which is like really the largest
telecom subscriber base in the world
it's like at least four times for mobile
phone users in the US market right now
and so we were a group of friends like
in college four years back I was and I
was doing my computer science in a
college called alpha thrusting in Kerala
and we were sitting in a campus and one
of my friend asked like how can i
impress a girl and so the immediate
answer was to google it and the problem
happened is that nobody has access to
Google and so that was the Eureka moment
like you know how about the people who
don't have access to Google can get
information any time and mobile was the
only solution that we were able to
deliver and so the next day we started
designing the prototype inside our
college campus like four of us decided
to do this pro I mean we were we were
not not at all wanted to start a company
after all we just want to basically
solve it
problem which is that lot of people
don't have access to internet and how
about giving an easy way and eventually
what happened is that we figured out
that nobody is doing it and we said our
cell like you know screw it let's do it
and we dropped out of college to start
the company and that's how it started so
what what the technology is so simple
like people who don't have access to
internet simply text in their query like
how they do on the internet they simply
send an SMS with the questions they want
to ask and we come across a different
partners and partners on the internet to
find the answer and it's in the back
instantly so we have multiple patents on
the technology and we are the only
movers in the field because we started
young and we call it SMS reinvention or
as summers 2.0 and these are like some
of the discussions that we did in
college and later we decided to form a
company because people are actively
using it and this is how it works simply
user send an SMS like it can be route
information it's like a GPS over SMS
where people send in a query and we send
them back with answer some people yeah
this is using Google search or something
but in tagging on an S it's it's aren't
it's a standardized search platform that
we developed like okay but what it
really matter is the people who are
offline right now
want to find information and people ask
crazy like you know some people ask
questions like this and we answer them
back and they become ands like you know
they become so happy that you know it's
so easy for people who are on the move
like it can be also Internet users but
there there are millions of ways like
you know like people lost questions when
they are even in the exam hall they ask
questions they get an answer things like
that but what happened is that you know
especially in small town cities and
towns like where people don't have a
channel to learn about things it can be
about sex education it can be about
things we which people are shy about
asking someone
they figure out that mobile becomes a
private companion and they started
asking us like millions of questions on
that and in in a short-term like in a
four year four years of being business
we become the largest in the in the
market we scale to 120 million users who
were tried to service so far daily
answering around two to three million
queries and I'm on three transaction of
one hundred million queries and so the
law is filling up do you want to switch
the oh yeah right now so live right now
these are the queries going through at
five o'clock in the morning on so right
now that is a cricket match going on and
that's why most of the queries are CRI
which means cricket and these are the
places from which the queries are coming
like these are the states AP stands for
interpretation
Orissa Karnataka and so and so so this
is what is happening right now at
probably six o'clock in the morning and
this is the harley count which is
showing onthe yeah
okay so coming back to the previous
slide our main age group is targeted on
the teenagers and college going students
who are like between 16 to 25 although
we have people who are like after 30
like you know people like my mom and dad
who might not even know what Google is
or like want to try the queries they
simply do this through SMS because
texting is something which people relate
to it as as an activity otherwise like
people make phone calls these are the
two things that people know and and main
traffic right now as interestingly from
small tire to tier 2 tier 3 cities where
people don't still don't have access to
any Internet and otherwise the the
places like in Mumbai Delhi and
Bangalore which are the main cities and
they are showing enough interest in
using the platform even though they have
still Internet connectivity at a limited
time we decided to become a global
company in the in the fact that you know
there were a lot of queries happening
from other emerging markets especially
from people places like Africa places
like you know Indonesia and all these
people and we look at the whole market
it's like 70% of the whole mobile phone
population still carries a mobile phone
with a less than 20% access to Internet
which is definitely a huge market to be
addressed and the other thing is that
not much of people are actually caring
about it or neglecting in the fact that
they will slowly come to the internet
more but what we realized at the very
early stages that there is a huge gap
like if Facebook want to go to the next
millions or billions of people on online
they need to come at least on a later
stage but here it's a addressable market
where there are a lot of people carrying
mobile phones and there is still no
access to the Internet and we are trying
to bridge that gap so this year probably
by the end of this year we would be live
in the 10 countries that we look forward
in working with and we look at a market
space of other than almost close to 2
million people who still don't have
access to Internet but have a mobile
phone at least and one of the all of
those revised it was
English language but yeah okay and the
other main thing on the interesting
thing that we are done with our platform
is that later we are realized as a small
company it's better to make the platform
public or make it open so that end
developers can create their own
applications on top of the simple
technology that we built so we created
an API for the platform where people
companies like Twitter companies like
Red Bus can create an application where
people can actually consume the Internet
in a light manner and it makes it's
interesting like you know we realized
that lot of people in India are actually
good developers and there is no place
for people to showcase this and we we
come across multiple apps which are
interesting for example Foursquare which
is right now one of the main active
application in Internet can actually go
offline people can check into places and
you know just let friends and family
know to where they are and the
opportunity is right in front of more
than 100 million who are still offline
and we do hackathons basically the
problem is that in India people only
relate to a place where there is only
Bollywood music and cricket so we
realized that you know it's not just
that like you know if you look at the
companies which has grown tremendously
big including son Google and all there
are people from India who are done on
the backend who are done something
really sustainably so well and we
realized that you know if we have a
platform for people who to you know
create applications and make it public
there are a lot of end results which can
happen and what interestingly happened
is that during the hackathons people can
develop SMS app so one one of the
interesting app we did one of one of the
hackathon participant which is an
eight-year-old kid the design was a
glass bunk app which it's like a it's
like a notification where you can record
your attendance over through SMS and
later at a stage if you want to know how
many class your bunk you get the answer
instantly so things like that
we conduct this more often in colleges
and campuses and it's going good and the
the core concept of the company is that
there are millions or even billions of
phones which are really dumb and we just
want to make them smart instead of just
focus on smart phones and which is a
sizeable or addressable market and we
feel that we can be the we can be the
strong player inside that some of the
recent press that we covered as as shown
in the figure and yep
it's a Limca Book of Records which is
like the the player platform which shown
as the largest offline search and we
were covered by Forbes as the law
emerging five startups to watch out how
we made it it's pretty simple we we have
we have a great team like all our young
a group of friends who are doing
business more than fun
and we addressed a saw a resize sizable
market which is huge and which is mobile
which is growing and we basically
started a company to solve a problem
which nobody has done before and that's
how the whole formation of a company and
incorporation happened later we had a
great set of mentors like right from the
start which helped us right from the
start to the place where we are right
now and we were being a good
storytellers a friend like we were able
to showcase our story in where our
places including all the places we went
and I think that is more important more
than being an entrepreneur owner of
entrepreneurship be a storyteller and
that's what makes were we are today and
that's it ok let's switch places one
more time oh and I've got a question for
you as as we're getting kind of set up
for this so tell me a little bit about
your revenue model basically you're
getting payments from the phone carriers
yes because you're increasing their SMS
traffic incredibly right so we've been
profitable for the last two years the
main monetization is basically the the
fact that every query is touched so in
Google people do the search for free
we're here every query is monitor
monitor and monetize through every
transaction which is happening so we we
typically make around 100 million
transactions per month that's the
traffic in terms of SMS which is every
query is like a charge that one rupees
per query so we make around 25 million
dollars per month per year in
transactions out of which for the
telecom operator and where we get a
revenue share okay and otherwise so
doing advertisers yeah so we
advertisements which specifically the
interesting part about our search
history is that we know what the Indians
are searching for and which is a big
data for you know a consumer market
companies for example using the red bus
bus ticketing platform they can book the
tickets over through SMS also or
companies like Flipkart can you know buy
books over through SMS
so all these lead generation itself is a
huge revenue monetization method for us
and otherwise the the data which we
collect based on the users it's an
interesting you know data for many
companies okay especially for internet
companies who really want to take the
internet into India we would be the
early movers for that okay okay
excellent
first of all Fanny can you see the
audience now yes I can see okay and can
you hear okay Danny can you hear okay
yes yes I can hear okay great then we're
ready for the Q&A let's open the floor
back in the back so I'm interested in
the topic of education because I feel
like a lot of the startups that have
come out of the US and our Silicon
Valley
I've been based in Stanford or you know
other universities people have great
ideas and they have most importantly the
expertise to develop them so if you're
talking about India which has yeah 1.2
billion people that are really in touch
with Indian issues but only a hundred
twenty million people that have access
to the internet to figure out how to
solve those issues I mean don't you
think that the biggest step in
developing a startup industry in India
would be educating those other you know
1.1 billion people
like how do you get them to a point they
actually
those very famous book that was written
a few years ago about the bottom right
that's exactly what a lot of these new
things are doing Oh would you want to
come berry yeah so I think we have to
break it up into two one is a 1.2
billion people is an opportunity as a
market the 100 million who are who are
educated in her access to Internet and
other tools are trying to solve the
reach and solve problems of this large
population one of them of course is
education to get them up up to a level
where you know there they don't only
have problems but they're capable of
solving and I think I knows for example
is doing just that
somebody like red bus is doing just that
so for example lot not all of red buses
customers have access to internet so he
has call centers so we are innovating to
serve this 1.2 billion people as a
market and of course they need to to be
brought up to the level where we bridge
this gap and lot of these innovations
and this whole ecosystem is actually
enabling that kind of bridging of the
gap in education itself for example we
are using technology to reach the
content in the last mile it you know
also to reach products to the last mile
and again the district is doing the same
by providing information to the last
mile so certainly it's an opportunity as
well as a challenge
that we looked at is okay we have a
little population and a every of these
countries is such a small tiny
population will it really add anything
to our revenues will it move the needle
and etcetera or not but what we missed
out in all these evaluations is when we
look at a billion population in India
it's not the billion population in India
actually if you go to Wikipedia and just
look up 85% of the way it lives below
the poverty line below $1 right the kind
of income so all it's not the billion
population at least the red buses
surveying talking to an acceptor it is a
small percentage of the 15% of the
billion population that is actually our
target consumer and in some countries
like Malaysia actually maybe forty five
percent of their thirty million
population is our target consumer which
makes it really sizable population
service so that way I would say that
let's not look at the billion population
let's look at that small fragmentation
that small percentage of customers who
really fall under our any of our
services
I thought it is he knows us Flipkart any
one of our services thanks let's do the
nice question actually this is pointed
over here I saw your hand first anyway
so we basically answer up to 480
characters in a response back which
which almost answer any question and
there is an interactive menu if you have
seen the slide pretty much closer there
is an option for people to retrieve more
results so it's it's a streamlined
method so I was interested because it
seems like you are key holders to open
this door for people there to access
information in a way that you know they
wouldn't otherwise be able to and that
seems like the most exciting potential
of it is infrastructure the biggest row
off for you in terms of signal towers
that are providing cellular service is
that I mean cell phones in people's
hands actually I think it's the opposite
right onion pens up internet penetration
is really low camera phones are a very
small percentage of the cell phone
market the other thing is that when we
tried to solve the problem we figured
out that SMS or texting is one medium
which is 99% of time other cases like
you know the even though there is a very
less signal you can't even make a call
but you simply can send an SMS so that
was okay so we we decided to top out of
the college because we got selected into
AI accelerator program which is a Y
Combinator model which was tried in I am
Hamid watt so what happened is that I
told my mom that I got MBA but later I
just say that she came to know about it
and by the time I've become you know the
media really helped by the way like
media really helped and also the support
from all the big entrepreneurs like few
of my angel investors were already doing
successful companies like founders of
Infosys people like that who supported
me like when we started that was
actually one of the you know back
backbone for us to like you know really
go to the next level and then see fine
finer
Bobby would you comment all that what
was your story like when you told your
family you're going to be an honor
yeah I spill my case it was different
my parents come from a village and all
through all through I went to a boarding
school in my kindergarten so that's how
I grew up completely outside so it must
have been quite a shock when you told
people you were going to leave TI right
the Jeep starts Red Bus around yes but
to my parents it was okay because they
had no clue what I was doing
right after my schooling I went to the
best of the college they didn't know
that it was the best of the college they
didn't know anything over Texas
Instruments getting when I said I'm
leaving that to set up a company they're
equally fine I so that way I was fine
but yeah the Bucks point I think media
media really really helped us so to give
to give this thing five years back when
I went to any conferences to speak about
entrepreneurship how we started etc and
all the second or the third question
used to be how did you convince your
parents and today when I go to any
conferences nobody nobody in the
audience asked how do you how do you
convince your parents well let me after
that show no change in the community and
the society that's happening earlier it
was a big question as to how did you
leave your job and today media has made
hero sort of us all of us are there in
CNBC's and newspapers almost every week
and then the country started worshiping
us and I think today parents are saying
okay I want my son to be an entrepreneur
like that and exits right now so I think
that is that's a big change that's
happening here how about you comment
yeah in 2007-2008 I had at least three
sets of parents who came to us to same
as it did investor's to convince their
son to leave the company
because he was not getting a good
marriage proposals I'm sure some of
these heroes help but it is changed out
there it is no longer as much so I must
say it still exists it's not gone but at
that time it was really very very
difficult for the guys to really know
start that right beep on a lot of a
couple things you said by the way I
think India will have come full circle
when your mother beats you with the
newspaper and says why aren't you
starting a company like Deepak I think
that closer of a circle but anyway my
question is you mentioned before
especially in all the presentations
someone touched on the opportunity you
talked a little bit about the gaps
what is India's every startup hub around
the world some type of or some couple
unique advantages that really they have
and my guess is maybe one of them in
India is that it's so there's so much
it's so difficult to get started
sometimes or to operate early stage
maybe that makes you better and tougher
as an entrepreneur that came up to
conference we read earlier in the week
so I wanted to know what do you think is
India's unique advantage that's the
tough one was nothing it changes but I
think the clearly the biggest advantage
is that we have a lot of unsolved
problems we have so many problems to be
solved and there are opportunities
execution is a huge challenge and that
makes us tougher I think that's that's
definitely the learning from the last
five years is that you cannot have the
luxury of of saying I'm doing something
great you have to just go do it because
you have so many obstacles to to come
through I think that is really an
advantage but biggest advantages there
are a lot of opportunities and if you
could convert that into a unique
solution and not just so you if you
innovate on the spot rather than coming
taking an idea like this they both
innovated on the spot pretty much and I
think that is is really a kind of a
unique strength the ecosystem is not
really there to nurture you right now it
is
coming there so you have to be a
self-starter and a lot of the guys are
those who succeed their self-starters I
think that is a innovation sure it's
different kinds of problems different
kinds of things about this is that these
are the problems that address you know
80% of the world's population that most
of the information technology revolution
has not done a whole lot for and if you
look at the countries where you know in
Oz is expanding in 2013 you know it's
not Germany is not France it's not
wherever it's countries that have
largely been missed so I think this is
really a very exciting new range of
ideas that are eventually going to
filter into the advanced economies as
well yes I think it's just that the
unique advantage today is that it's beer
at a time
where the problems are really ready to
be solved and I think that is it's a
it's a unique time in history probably
from emerging economies back in the back
my experience so one of the things is I
think we are blessed by having the
seamless internet is seamless internet
access or the access to the world's
knowledge for example I mean this I am
talking with my with my experience of
going to China and then I was shocked
that you they don't have access to
Google to Facebook and the Facebook's
there and the googles there or it is the
travel technology there they don't have
access to the I mean Galileo which are
the largest which are which are the
largest GDS of travel technology across
the world and that doesn't exist in
china because chinese government didn't
allow it so they have their homegrown
GDS which is very very kind of predated
and some of the some of the things that
they use are quite predated I think one
other way we are blessed is by allowing
all these technology companies to be
present in India and make
us compete with them that way and about
last year when I came to the valley
to California I met I went to the
startup Center met some startups and
looked at what they were working on and
I was very pleasantly happy that our
engineers are our team the technologies
that they're working on are they worked
on in the last two quarters are the
technologies that the valley
entrepreneurs are working on when I
visited them so I think by having this
direct access to the the next big
innovation for the human race whether it
is published on TechCrunch or any one of
these blocks Indians here we get access
to that the next minute and we start
working on it you know very almost like
a paranoid phase thinking about okay
maybe maybe it's already happened in the
US and let's work on it and etc so that
way I think we are leveraging the best
of the technologies we are getting
visibility into the best of the
technologies and we are deploying it
much earlier so that is one advantage
that we have
which is not so common in other
countries and the second one is I think
we are also blessed by our large market
for example when I met this entrepreneur
in Malaysia who wanted to build a red
bus in Malaysia we exchanged notes as to
what we do what he does and etc etc and
all that and towards the end of that he
told me that if ever we are expanding to
Malaysia I should do a favor to him and
when I asked him what it was he said
when you are expanding to Malaysia the
first thing that you should do is to
acquire me because there is no way that
with this market I will be able to build
technology like you have built and when
you come here customers are customers
they like the best of the technologies
bus operators like the best of the
technologies and you will overtake me
and that's just because of the I mean
variable to invest in such technologies
because the large consumer population
that we have which some of these other
countries are not able to so I think
that is also an advantage
that we have which is enabling us to
take our technology which we have anyway
built to other countries we're building
that technology is not Sophie's okay
thank you funny I think we have time for
one more question and I had already
recognized you in the back go for it
that's maybe to all the three of you how
can you stimulate entrepreneurship in
say the rural parts of India like sort
of decentralized this currently seems
like it's coming from the urban parts
from a specific sort of almost class in
society do you think it's even possible
to sort of push the solution generation
out to where the problems or the most
demanding needs are okay this is a very
interesting question should
entrepreneurship really stay in urban
centers where you're looking out at the
rural areas and imagining their problems
or can it really be distributed to the
rural areas and really have you know
ideas come up from the rural areas yeah
you like that yeah sure so again going
back to what you mentioned about the
base of the pyramid book and with you
know we are looking at that as a big
market and that's that's a big
opportunity there so there are there are
other sort of solutions which are
emerging from there but for skimming
them for technology we bring them for
scale up that's where I think the the
urban centers or the educational
institutions are coming in and that's
what a great opportunity exists for
synergistic existence I think there has
to be a an upward and downward looking
approach and the local entrepreneurship
has to be developed and that is
happening as well there are certain
solutions happening in energy water and
Agri sectors which are very localized
and you know they're also getting access
to technology I like funny mentioned
there is access though it may not be as
seamless but there is access there and
in in particularly in water and
agriculture and I think suddenly has
some examples as well some other another
venture capitalist from India these
things are happening so local centers
are developing so certainly it is it is
going to spread
okay I'm going to have to Colin into the
formal session I've got a question each
for funny and for Deepak to end this up
okay we are going to put these up on
YouTube eventually so people all over
are going to see this session what
advice would you give to somebody who is
interested in becoming an entrepreneur
oh so from me I think this taking can be
easier when you start young and you can
use your and easy to save in your young
yeah that's always always good to start
young uh-huh and because you don't have
much of a commitment right now like you
know your parents are capable of taking
you to college you can spend a lot of
time in college have a lot of free time
there is Wi-Fi access all those things
are here and just to utilize those is
what people should do actually and
that's what we did and I think a lot of
people in India are you know following
up what we are done so far and taking
our case as a good story for them to
inspire and start off and I feel you
know I think when you start young you
you can take a lot of risk and when you
become old you can tell stories later
and I think that's how it was we have
been benefited because of the mentoring
program that we received I have strongly
believe that people who want to be
entrepreneurs the first generation young
entrepreneurs should certainly look for
those mentors who have the wisdom and
the knowledge has to have seen cycles of
companies in our case our mentor
accurately kind of predicts what is
going to happen in the next quarter to
us in terms of our organization in terms
of people chemistry in terms of
competition doing something to us and
etc so that's very very valuable and
that comes only with experience so I
would certainly say that I have great
mentors and believe in them 100% ok
thanks I've got a final announcement we
want to thank is identify our major
support of this series we also want to
thank the Allen Minor foundation for
supporting this year
thanks to our support we've got some
refreshments outside everybody here we'd
love to have you stay and talk with each
other and also talk with our speakers
finally thank you so much for joining us
at very early morning and thanks
everybody for coming please join me in
thanking our panel
you